about a year ago um soon after I got my
first job I invested into an IU IL due
to talking to my parents financial
advisor I kind of decided I would like
to get out of this however the problem
is is there's a surrender charge so I
have about um I've invested since last
November and I have about like $1,500
invested but if I were to try I can't
transfer it into anything else if I try
to leave it I'd be left with $400 well
it sounds like you've lost $1,100 to me
yeah make note that this guy screwed you
putting you into this product I mean put
you in a product that the only way you
avoid surrender charges is 10 years man
I'm sorry this is we file this one under
stupid tax and we've all paid our
version of it but I hate that you have
to deal with this and lose that 11100